(audience applauding)
I'm so excited for this.
Jordan James, my hero,
come on up here, please.
(rock music)
(audience cheering and applauding)
Hi.
Thank you.
Thank you so much
for first of all, coming on this show.
Okay, so "Good Deeds Buffalo."
Now, how did you do this?
And I'm sorry, but mad respect to you
getting a show on broadcast television.
(audience cheering and applauding)
It's not easy.
I can't believe Drew Barrymore is saying this to me.
'Cause it's hard.
It is.
It's been so challenging, but Buffalo, Western, New York
the community has been so wonderful.
They have jumped on board and have been so supportive.
And I think with my determination
they weren't gonna say no. (laughs)
It just wasn't gonna happen.
And you're somebody.
(audience applauding)
You are somebody who inspires me to be myself
because you've always been unapologetically Drew Barrymore.
And that is something that I aim to be like.
Thank you so much for that.
(audience applauding)
For me, it's about looking back at those dark days
of being in high school and being bullied
and those other kids and their stories.
I wanna be able to do it for them
because they probably didn't feel like they could do it.
And so here I am.
(audience applauding)
And you are.
How do you approach the content of your show?
So for anything that we do on the show,
it has to come from the heart.
When I get the nominations, I research these folks
and I really get to know their story.
And if it doesn't resonate with me,
if it doesn't give me the chills, we don't do it.
But I'll tell you, everybody so far that I've been,
Buffalo is a beautiful place.
We truly are the city of good neighbors.
(audience applauding)
And I think those are what keep me going, those people.
It's funny too
because meeting people that you didn't know before.
I can't believe I'm here right now.
(Drew laughs)
This is crazy.
Ah!
Sorry to interrupt.
Are you kidding?
Do it.
(Jordan laughs)
Well we have a banter going.
Yes, I love it.
This job makes me happy.
Does it make you happy?
It absolutely does.
I think
(audience applauding)
it absolutely does.
Kindness, being kind is like the only thing you can give
but you don't run out of.
And being able to do this job,
I get to be kind to which I am, and I get to magnify it.
It's such a beautiful thing.
I'm so thankful.
Can I ask like, you have been through a lot in your life.
Do you think it was part
of the road to being an empathic person?
I truly believe so.
And thank you for acknowledging that I'm empathic
because I've felt that I'm very empathic in my life.
And I think with my mom's passing in 2019
I made the decision to donate her organs.
And three months later, I received a letter
in the mail from a gentleman who received her corneas.
And when I got that message,
(audience applauding)
it filled me with joy to know that somebody
would be able to see again
and be able to vision and see the life that my mom once saw.
And I think that's what really pushed me to wanna learn more
about these stories because there's so many out there.
And is it true also that you.
(audience applauding)
I'm like, oh.
Is it true also that through being an organizer
of blood donations, that you've also like have the data
on the fact that 800 lives have been affected
through the blood drives?
Like 800 lives have been saved because of your blood drives?
Yes, thank you.
(audience applauding)
It's sometimes hard to comprehend that I did this
but it's so beautiful.
And I think when I get to share that story with people
and they feel that they can do something,
that's what I do it all for.
To spark that motivation to do what they've wanted to do.
Is it true that you haven't been able
to get some suits for the show
and you would like to get some suits for the show?
Yes, so, because we launched in the middle of pandemic,
our sponsors pay directly for production.
There's no money in it for me.
But it's not about that.
It's about their stories.
So we've been able to do this show.
In eight months, we did 13 episodes.
(audience applauding)
And all of the money is basically just covering the cost.
Just covering just cost.
No extras.
Nos extras.
So I've never been able to own a suit in my life
or clothes that you would wear on television.
So I decided to go to The Salvation Army and here we are.
(audience applauding)
Well, there is this wonderful company called Indochino
and they're a custom suiting and apparel company.
And so they're gonna give you $2,500
to make some custom for your suits.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I don't know how to, thank you, thank you so much.
Well, also, I like the idea of something
being made specifically for you.
Yes, to have something for myself.
Well, and you'll be doing it in style.
(lively music)